bah
les commerces de gaza sont bombardés et
les incendies causés par les frappes
israéliennes continuent de détruire des
bâtiments
les forces de défense civile font tout
pour les etam
mais les conséquences de cette tragédie
sont là la destruction de la tour al
chourouk mais aussi de magasins aux
alentours
certains tenanciers ont perdu le travail
de toute une vie
la crise dieu coronavirus nous a bien
sûr fait mal comme au reste du monde
nous sommes dans la même situation que
quiconque dans tous les autres pays les
pertes et la paralysie économique à
cause du coronavirus sont partout les
mêmes et nous espérions que pendant la
fête
le seigneur serait miséricordieux envers
nous et envers tout le monde mais les
vents ne soufflent pas comme les navires
le bol les affrontements ont commencé
cette tour a été détruite
nous avons été touchés par ces fragments
et parle on explose plus de 200 magasins
ont été touchés ceux qui travaillaient
se retrouvent sans ressources est déjà
responsable de lourdes pertes humaines
ces raids ont également bouleversé la
vie des survivants
cette saison on s'attendait à ce qu'il
soit possible de vendre les produits
disponibles
et puis la guerre est venue on n'a pas
réussi à les vendre ni à faire quoi que
ce soit la zone a été bombardée le
magasin était détruit les marchandises
ont été endommagés le travail s'est
arrêté on ne peut pas travailler on ne
peut pas vendre
donc nous restons ici les bras croisés
il n'y a plus de travail partout à gaza
on peut voir des dizaines d'édifices en
ruine les bombardements tu détruisent
des rues et des infrastructures
les raids israéliens s'intensifie et le
nombre de victimes parmi les
palestiniens n'a de cesse d'augmenter
ici se dressaient des bâtiments
gouvernementaux des maisons des écoles
des fermes des terres des réseaux
d'électricité de distribution d'eau et
d'assainissement
il n'en reste que des ruines cela ne
ressemble pas à une simple escalade mais
plutôt à une guerre qui pourrait encore
s'aggraver